[Music]  Zsa Zsa Gabor has died at 99 her husband  Frederick Prince von Anhalt lzt she died  at home with him by her side just months  shy of her 100th birthday Gabor rose to  fame in the 1950s and continued to make  on-screen appearances into the mid-90s  until she was plagued by health issues  the actress was also known for having  been married nine times including a  marriage to Conrad Hilton the Hungarian  born socialite is survived by her  husband of 30 years and their son Marcus  several stars took to social media to  mourn Kapoor's death including Larry  King who tweeted there will only be one  Zsa Zsa Gabor and I liked her a lot  rest in peace my dear Piers Morgan  reflected on Gabor's life and legacy  while fellow iconic actress Barbara Eden  called Gabor lovely and always fun and  delightful to be around